[Musique]
vu les hornets
c'est encore une belle journée 28 degrés
et autant d'activités possibles à
glendale
quand je vous regarde chers élèves je
vois un monde d'opportunités
alors foncez et donner tout ce que vous
avez pour devenir la meilleure personne
possible
certains disent que vous êtes une
génération perdue mais avec la bonne
attitude
vous pouvez conquérir le monde
je refuse de sous-estimer l'enthousiaste
de la jeunesse je suis convaincu que les
enfants sont notre avenir
qu'est ce que je voudrais faire plus
tard être le boss de l'apocalypse
m
bye
accrochez vos ceintures les petits bill
ça va être chaud vous pensiez que
l'apocalypse était pas fun vous aviez
tort